je stresse à mieux comprendre et
découvrir davantage ce nouveau site de
création contemporaine qui va ouvrir ses
portes au public dès demain
jérôme sens bonsoir bonjour à l'un des
deux dirigeants de ce palais une
institution créée pour l'exposition
internationale de 1937 et que vous
voulez finalement une onde institution
un lieu ouvert à toutes les disciplines
absolument le poète tokyo on souhaite
que ça soit sur deux laboratoires pour
la création contemporaine il manqué à
paris un lieu souplesse hexyle plus
flexible entre les grandes institutions
que nous avons déjà le centre georges
pompidou le musée d'art moderne de paris
le centre national de la photographie
il manquait un lieu laboratoire sans
prétention dans lequel les créateurs
puissent intervenir de manière simple et
transversale on souhaite être un lieu
interdisciplinaire où les arts visuels
puissent dialoguer avec la mode le
cinéma la littérature et la musique
laurie quelques images de l'intérieur du
bâtiment dont on voyait également
quelques heures comment avez vous conçu
d'abord le lieu lui
on voit que ça ressemble déjà comme une
sorte de chantiers inachevés pourquoi
parceque il me semblait que pour
illustrer un laboratoire pour que les
artistes aient un lieu qui ressemble à
un laboratoire le laisser dans l'état
dans lequel était sûr de friches
industrielles / de d'échafaudages à
partir duquel tous les artistes pourrait
inventer ce lieu nous semblait plus
cohérent que de faire une sorte de
d'architecturé showroom trop bien fait
trop peu décorez prix trop d'éléments
décoratifs donc les architectes anne
lacaton et jean-philippe vassal ont
désiré avoir pour votre très minimale
par rapport à l'enjeu architecturale ça
veut dire aussi que ce lieu est conçu un
peu comme un sou je crois comme la place
djemaa el fna à marrakech
ça veut dire qu à toute heure de la
journée ont enfin de midi à minuit
il se passe quelque chose de différent
le lieu évolué avec les gens qui sont là
absolument c'est la référence est très
bonne puisque c'est une place qui a
presque deux temps celui du jour est
celui de la nuit un peu comme celui du
palais tokyo qu'on souhaite
effectivement existé entre midi et
minuit
un lieu qui pourra avoir deux
temporalités différentes
c'est une manière de réagir aussi
d'offrir au public les moyens de voir
les expositions hors de leur temps de
travail puisque très souvent les musées
ou les actions d'art sont ouvertes
pendant le temps de travail est ce que
vous pensez que l'habitude va pouvoir
secret parce que finalement n'a pas le
l'occasion d'aller tard dans les musées
à ce que vous pensez suggérer comment
d'ailleurs vous allez suggéré aux gens
finalement de de sortir de chez eux à
20h à 22h on va pas finalement palais de
tokyo comme on va au louvre ou à bourg
tout à fait cas on souhaite se faire du
palais de tokyo
un lieu de vie un lieu de vie où une
maison des créateurs ou pour s y
retrouver toutes les tribus la création
général un endroit simple l'on puisse
aller sans véritablement réfléchir puis
ce qu'il se passera tous les deux jours
un événement qu'il s'agisse d'un concert
un débat un dialogue et un colloque
parlez-nous jérôme sens des oeuvres que
nous voyons ici là je crois que c'est un
marché à thaïlandais absolument c'est
participer se raser qu'une longue qui
reprend les et du marché qui pose la
question de la valeur des oeuvres d'art
et s'il va organiser deux fois veulent
cette semaine une vente à chacun des
objets à 1 euro alors installations
performances vidéo on trouve de tout au
palais de tokyo est ce que vous n'ayez
pas peur ou est ce que vous avez au
contraire envie de déranger un peu
quelque part les gens est ce que en même
temps vous allez prendre un peu par la
main parce que ceux qui n'ont pas la
culture de l'art contemporain est ce que
est ce qu'ils vont pas être un peu perdu
au palais de tokyo
je ne crois pas puisque notre désir est
de mettre la création les artistes à
proximité nous allons d'ailleurs pensé à
mettre dans les salles non pas des
gardiens mais des médiateurs des jeunes
personnes qui sont là pour engager le
débat répond aux questions du public
par ailleurs nous avons une
programmation hors de nos murs qui
s'appelle tokyo rama qui consiste un
parc ont scénarisé par des créateurs
qu'ils s'agissent de chefs cuisiniers de
couturiers de jeunes artistes qui emmène
le public de 20 50 personnes avec eux
dans ce parcours dans le quartier pour
que l'on vous prend par la main on vous
laissera pas tout seul au palais tokyo
si vous êtes désemparés merci d'être
venu nous parler du palais tokyo
ouverture dès demain 26 2010 à minuit
avec chaque jour à prendre un programme
d'événements particuliers merci beaucoup
gérant de santé